are you ready to craft more devious
courses and Super Mario maker the next
set of tools will let you take the
trolling to the next level I'm Tony and
this is your GameSpot news update
straight from the Mushroom Kingdom
first up you can shake a swamp to turn
it into a skewer falling Rock enemies
are definitely intimidating but those
spiked columns are a whole nother story
the real game changer is the key without
it you won't be able to open locked
doors give a key to a boss and you'll be
forced to defeat the big baddie before
you can move on to make things even
tougher you can also create pink coins
you'll have to collect them all to earn
the key on top of all that the game is
getting a new super expert mode if you
clear expert mode on hunter mario
challenge you'll unlock an even harder
set of levels Super Mario maker gets all
this new content on March 9th you guys
have already built over 6 million
courses with the current toolset and
these new additions will open the door
for even meaner courses especially if
that door requires a key to keep up with
all the big Nintendo news keep it locked
to game spot